le croissance cette année en france avec
le troisième confinement versier déjà
revu ses ambitions à la baisse sera 5%
tout au plus contre 6% prévus jusqu'ici
alors dans quelle mesure cette mise à
l'arrêt de pans entiers de l'économie
étaient une menace pour la reprise ces
vents contraires ne risque-t-il pas de
reléguer notre pays on peut peloton dans
la compétition internationale
c'est l'objet de l'édito échos ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques sapir le nouveau
confinement que l'on vit actuellement à
fait l'effet d'une douche froide qu'elle
va en être le coup et quelles en seront
les conséquences pour l'économie vaste
question bonsoir stéphanie oui
effectivement ce troisième confinement
que le président macro aurait bien voulu
visiblement éviter
eh bien il va coûter cher à coûter cher
à l'économie alors d'abord il a coûté au
niveau des aides que ce soit le chômage
partiel
le fonds de solidarité il va coûter
aussi en termes de croissance parce que
on peut penser que la croissance
française va perdre l'équivalent d'un
point de fibres et puis évidemment il va
coûter cher en perte de revenus fiscaux
et donc c'est trois coups vont s' d'une
certaine manière ce combiné et vont
tirer vers le bas
l'économie française alors jacques tout
d'abord que va coûter à l'état ce
nouveau confinement
alors bercy a fait des prévisions et on
voit que pour un confinement d'un mois
on ne sait pas s'il ne durera qu'un mois
il paye peut durer durer plus et bien il
y aurait si on fait l'addition du fonds
de solidarité qui aide les entreprises
et les particuliers
le chômage partiel les exemptions
fiscales
il y aurait à peu près 11 milliards
d'euros qui seraient dépensées pour un
confinement d'un mois évidemment s'il
devait durer plus long et bien
l'addition s'alourdirait jacques le coup
ce n'est pas seulement ce que l'état
dépense mais aussi moins de richesses
produites et donc moins d'impôts oui
tout à fait vous avez tout à fait raison
c'est fini et là on va le voir
on a là aussi des estimations qui ont
été faites par bercy qui ont été faites
par la banque de france et on pense
qu'il y aura donc une perte de
croissance d'environ un point de pipe là
d'ici la fin du mois d'avril et le début
du mois de mai après il ya évidemment
les conséquences cela et on voit très
bien que les recettes fiscales puisqu'il
ya moins d'activités vont baisser et là
encore ça ajoute l'équivalent de 11
milliards d'euros ce qui fait que
globalement la dette et le déficit
budgétaire pour 2021 devrait monter
encore là aussi de l'équivalent d'un
pour cent du pib' alors chacun dans ce
contexte comment la france si j'étais
lent en europe
c'est évidemment un point et déjà il ya
un premier décrochage de la france par
rapport à nos voisins directs européens
alors même si les autres pays ont été
tout autant toucher que nous par exemple
en allemagne on parle d'un reconfirme
ans on parle d'un durcissement des
mesures sanitaires en italie bref et
comme on le voit là sur le graphique est
bien en réalité la france a été un des
pays qui ont été les plus touchées
justement par la crise du que vides
alors ce qui est quand même extrêmement
inquiétant c'est qu'on voit aussi que la
france est un des pays qui se relève le
plus lentement alors que ce soit par
rapport à l'allemagne
évidemment par rapport à la suède mais
même dans le cas du royaume uni le
royaume uni qui est le seul pays qui a
été en fait en dessous de nous au niveau
de la crise du coc vide assez assez
largement
eh bien il va nous rattraper pourquoi
parceque ils ont une politique de
vaccination qui est beaucoup plus
agressive qui est beaucoup plus réussie
il faut le dire que la france est donc
tout cela se conjugue pour faire que la
france en fait se retrouve avec l'italie
tout à fait en queue de peloton alors
jacquin la france est elle aussi en
mauvaise position si on la compare avec
les résultats des autres pays développés
oui et ça stéphanie c'est quelque chose
qui est aussi extrêmement important
c'est peut-être là où ça se voit
de la manière la plus nette si vous
voulez ce risque de déclassement qui est
un 2e des classements cette fois ci plus
avec nos voisins européens mais avec les
grands pays développés
alors pourquoi il n'y a pas que la cause
de la crise bien sûr l'aco vide a joué
très largement
mais il ya aussi une mauvaise gestion de
la crise sanitaire et il y a bien
entendu
l'absence des plans de relance alors on
voit là il ya trois problèmes qui se
posent
le premier problème ça a été la
désindustrialisation de la france
l'économie française est aujourd'hui
très largement une économie de services
et c'est ce qui explique que le choc de
la coved et été plus brutal pour nous
par exemple que pour les états unis
évidemment pour le japon pour la russie
pour la corée est un con ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point
évidemment ce sont des politiques
sanitaires qui n'ont pas été optimale il
faut bien lire nos politiques sanitaires
alors bombe
nous avons fait peut-être un peu moins
de bêtises que des pays comme les etats
unis ou comme le brésil mais nous
n'avons pas non plus réussi réellement
les choses et de ce point de vue là le
japon et la corée s'en tire nettement
mieux que nous et puis il ya un
troisième point qui est encore plus
important c'est les mesures de relance
et on voit là que les mesures de relance
que ce soit celles qui ont été prises au
niveau européen où que ce soit celles
qui sont prises à l'échelon français
reste très en deçà de ce qui est fait
alors que ce soit en allemagne
que ce soit aux états unis en
particulier donc c'est pour ça qu'on
peut parler d'un risque de déclassement
par rapport aux grandes puissances
alors je ne vous aviez aussi parlé dans
une précédente émission du retard que
l'on serait en train de prendre avec
asie oui tout à fait et il l'a encore si
vous voulez il ya des choses qui sont
très inquiétantes
alors bien sûr il ya le cas de la chine
qui a connu une virée une réduction de
sa croissance mais qui n'est pas rentré
en récession en 2020 tout comme le
vietnam
mais si on regarde là encore ce
graphique on voit que même si ces pays
ont un niveau de richesse par habitant
qui est inférieur à celui de la france
bon ce qui est pratiquement le cas de
tous ces pays malgré tout la croissance
alors qui est attendu en 2021 mais
encore plus celle qui est attendu pour
2022 2023 ou 2024 va les propulser très
au delà de du niveau que la france
pourrait atteindre est donc là encore il
ya un troisième type de décrochage alors
qu'ils n'affectent pas que la france qui
affectera aussi les pays de l'union
européenne par rapport à ce qui va
devenir maintenant de manière tout à
fait évidente
le pôle de croissance du monde c'est à
dire
l'asie orientale et l'extrême orient de
la manière la plus large alors serait
justement des prévisions de croissance
pour 2021 en france est ce que ce sera
le dernier
il faut l'espérer mais ce n'est
malheureusement pas sûr on voit très
bien d'ailleurs comment l'évolution de
la situation sanitaire détermine d'une
certaine manière l'évolution de la
situation économique
si jamais il devait y avoir un quatrième
confinement les conséquences en seraient
tout à fait eu tout à fait dramatique et
on en voit aussi à quel point la
politique de vaccination joue un rôle
très important pour la reprise dans les
pays qui ont été très touchés par
l'épidémie et est de ce point de vue là
on ne peut que regretter le retard qui a
été pris au niveau français et au niveau
européen d'une certaine manière parce
que la deux de ce point de vue là nous
ne faisons pas pire que les autres pays
de l'union européenne mais nous faisons
très nettement moins bien que le royaume
uni ou que les états unis est donc si je
comprends bien jacques on est loin
d'être tiré d'affaires hélas oui hélas
oui c'est vraiment là une question qui
est extrêmement importante
la france a été particulièrement touchée
par cette crise je voulais dit parce que
nous payons d'une certaine manière le
prix de 30 années de
désindustrialisation et c'est la raison
pour laquelle l'économie française a été
si particulièrement touchées en
particulier si on la compare par exemple
avec l'allemagne qui a été moins qu'ils
aient été moins touchée alors qu'elle
subit désormais le même niveau de crise
sanitaire que nous alors que la russie
aussi qui a été nettement moins touché
que nous donc ça c'est le premier point
une politique sanitaire qui n'est pas
l'une des meilleures
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire bon
même dire qu'elle on a été mauvais dans
toute une série de questions
et puis surtout cette absence des plans
de relance ou dix ans cette faiblesse
des plans de relance qui risque de
retarder le redémarrage de l'économie
française
et ce sont ces trois raisons d'une
certaine manière qui me font craindre un
décrochage de l'économie française que
ce soit en europe que ce soit par
rapport aux grands
développer ou que ce soit par rapport à
ce qu'on appelle les pays de l'asie
émergente